space tourism is much closer than you
may think
the international space station will
soon retire from its successful run
through low earth orbit but humanity's
next home in space is already preparing
to launch
what will future space stations look
like
what will we use them for
and how soon could you walk aboard one
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you visited earth's next space
station
in the past two decades the
international space station has hosted
over 250 astronauts from all around the
world
the iss is used as a research facility
in low earth orbit
there scientists study anything from
microgravity to new medical techniques
their research is what's fueling our
future interplanetary travel
but as with all good things the iss
won't last forever
it's already experiencing air leaks and
other system failures
but when the time comes to put it out of
commission in 2030 the door to space
will be wide open for the next wave of
explorers
that brings us to the current quest to
develop humanity's next generation space
modules
if you want a glimpse a new exhibit in
dubai's museum of the future provides a
look at the next stage of low earth
orbital concepts
so
what might future modules actually look
like
think you need to be an astronaut to go
to space
well i've got news for you
private companies are now stepping in to
launch multiple space stations into
orbit within the next decade and soon
space tourism will be so readily
available
you might be able to see our big blue
marble of a home planet with your own
eyes
that is if you have the money
because private companies have stepped
in to cover some of the space bills
agencies like nasa can focus on getting
us to mars and pushing the ongoing
exploratory missions beyond our
planetary neighborhood
for you
that means a new era of space travel is
right around the corner
and you've got some options to get there
a little cheaper
spacex's dragon spacecraft are already
transporting astronauts to the iss
so far it's saved nasa as much as 30
billion dollars
still a window seat for an astronaut
still costs around 50 million dollars
so maybe don't stop saving just yet
jeff bezos's company blue origin has
designed their own low earth orbit space
station orbital reef
you'll notice that the station will
feature the usual research labs but you
could also use their onboard 3d printers
and do some gardening off earth
i don't know about you but my top
priority in space would be premium
printing services
all the best hotels have that right
well axiom space is already building
models for the iss
including a space hotel
it will attach to the iss while it's
still operational
then this galactic hotel will live as
its own space station
you could look out its massive windows
overlooking earth and use its large
entertainment systems
if you want to start a business in orbit
axiom will custom build a module for any
manufacturing you want to do
you could even make new modules
that's quite a rental unit
or maybe you're looking for something
with more moon-based potential
sierra space has examples of inflatable
living areas called life habitats
large integrated flexible environment
which include crew quarters closets and
more importantly better bathrooms
the idea is to use these as
free-floating space stations that you
could one day land on the moon
it would include a rocket launch pad to
get home and even a nuclear power plant
think of this as a galactic pit stop on
your way to mars
so can you picture what it's like to be
on one of those space stations yet
well if you don't want to wait for years
or shell out that kind of cash you're in
luck
that's what the orbital space station
hope space station is for
and it's right here on earth at dubai's
museum of the future
you'll see replicas of space shuttles
and learn about the cool futuristic
capabilities that are currently underway
above our atmosphere
you could learn about how photovoltaic
cells on the moon are used to beam
microwave energy back to earth
or go and learn about the missions space
pioneers will soon take on
of course you can always gaze right back
at our earth without having to
experience the g-forces to get there or
the bills of space hotel room service
the museum of the future features much
more than space exploration
here you can learn what awaits you down
on earth too
from tomorrow today where you can see
the prototypes of exciting new
technologies that will improve our ways
of living on this planet to future
heroes where the youngest visitors will
discover their future selves through fun
activities
al waha level will teach you to enjoy
life without technology and reconnect
with your inner self
and finally vault of life where you
could understand nature in the
rainforest ecosystem simulator
this is a place where you can glimpse
into the future touch the future and
shape the future yourself
and if you're a space enthusiast willing
to brush shoulders with some of the
world's best space-minded entrepreneurs
the museum of the future plans to be an
incubator to collaborate and innovate on
earth orbit habitats and beyond
and who knows maybe we'll start building
a superstructure in space sooner than we
expect
how about a dyson sphere around the sun
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you